Tenía 10 años cuando supe lo que significaba la palabra "genocidio".
Era el 2003,
y mi pueblo estaba siendo brutalmente atacado debido a su raza...
cientos de miles asesinados,
millones desplazados,
una nación desgarrada a manos de su propio gobierno.
Mi madre y mi padre de inmediato se manifestaron en contra de la crisis.
Realmente no lo entendía,
salvo por el hecho de que estaba destruyendo a mis padres.
Un día, encontré a mi madre llorando,
y le pregunté por qué estábamos sepultando a tanta gente.
No recuerdo las palabras que eligió
para describirle el genocidio a su hija de 10 años,
pero recuerdo el sentimiento.
Nos sentimos completamente solas,
como si nadie pudiera oírnos,
como si fuéramos prácticamente invisibles.
Fue cuando escribí mi primer poema sobre Darfur.
Escribí poesía para convencer a la gente de que nos escuchara y nos viera,
y así es como descubrí aquello que me cambiaría.
Es fácil ser visto.
Quiero decir, mírenme: soy una joven africana con un pañuelo en mi cabeza,
acento americano en mi lengua,
y una historia que hace que parezcan atractivas
las más brutales mañanas de lunes.
Pero es difícil convencer a la gente de que merecen ser vistos.
Lo aprendí un día en la secundaria, cuando mi profesor me pidió
que hiciera una presentación sobre Darfur.
Estaba configurando el proyector cuando una compañera de clase dijo:
"¿Por qué tienes que hablar de esto?
¿Qué no piensas en nosotros y en cómo nos hará sentir?".
(Risas)
Mi ser de 14 años de edad no sabía qué decirle,
o cómo explicar el dolor que sentí en ese momento,
y en cada momento que nos vimos forzados a no hablar de "esto".
Sus palabras me remontaron a los días y las noches en el suelo en Darfur,
cuando nos vimos forzados a permanecer en silencio;
cuando no platicábamos en el té de la mañana
porque los aviones de guerra sobrevolando se tragarían cualquier sonido;
a los días en que nos dijeron
no solo que no merecíamos ser escuchados
sino que no teníamos derecho a existir.
Y ahí fue donde ocurrió la magia,
en esa aula cuando todas las estudiantes comenzaron a sentarse
y empecé a hablar,
a pesar de esa renovada sensación de que no merecía estar allí,
de que no pertenecía allí
y de que no tenía derecho a romper el silencio.
Mientras hablaba,
y mis compañeras de clase escuchaban,
el miedo menguó.
Mi mente se calmó
y me sentí segura.
Fue el sonido de nuestra aflicción,
la sensación de sus brazos envolviéndome,
las firmes paredes que nos mantenían unidas.
No se sintió como un vacío.
Elegí la poesía porque es muy visceral.
Cuando alguien está de pie delante de uno, mente, cuerpo y alma,
diciendo "Sé mi testigo",
es imposible no ser profundamente consciente de la propia humanidad.
Esto cambió todo para mí.
Me dio coraje.
Cada día experimento el poder del testimonio,
y por ello, soy plena.
Y ahora pregunto:
¿Serían mis testigos?
Me dan el micrófono
al tiempo en que mis hombros se hunden bajo el peso de este estrés.
La mujer dice,
"El refugiado un millón acaba de salir de Sudán del Sur.
¿Algún comentario?".
Siento mis pies balancearse sobre los tacones que mi madre compró,
insinuando la pregunta:
¿Nos quedamos, o es más seguro si elegimos volar?
En mi mente resuenan los números:
un millón fallecidos,
dos millones desplazados,
400 000 muertos en Darfur.
Y este nudo ahoga mi garganta,
como si cada cuerpo acabara de encontrar una tumba
aquí mismo en mi esófago.
El que fuera nuestro país,
todo el norte y sur y este y oeste,
tan inquieto que ni el Nilo podía mantenernos unidos,
y me pides que resuma.
Hablan de los números como si todavía no estuviera sucediendo,
como si 500 000 no hubieran muerto en Siria,
como si 3 000 no fuesen testigos
en el fondo del Mediterráneo,
como si no hubiera volúmenes enteros llenos de hojas con hechos
sobre nuestros genocidios,
y ahora quieren que escriba uno.
Hecho:
nunca hablamos durante el desayuno,
porque los aviones de guerra se tragaban nuestras voces.
Hecho:
mi abuelo no quiso abandonar su casa,
así que murió en zona de guerra.
Hecho:
un arbusto ardiente sin Dios es solo un fuego.
Mido la distancia entre lo que sé
y lo que es seguro decir en un micrófono.
¿Hablo de pena? ¿De desplazamiento?
¿Hablo de la violencia,
de cómo nunca es tan simple como se ve en la televisión,
de cómo pasan semanas plagadas de miedo antes de que enciendan la cámara?
¿Le hablo de nuestros cuerpos,
de que son 60 % agua,
pero aun así, ardemos como madera seca,
haciendo combustible de nuestro sacrificio?
¿Le digo que los hombres murieron primero, las madres forzadas vieron la matanza?
¿Que vinieron por nuestros hijos,
y los dispersaron por el continente hasta hundir nuestros hogares?
¿Que hasta los castillos se hunden ante la voracidad de las bombas?
¿Le hablo de los ancianos,
nuestros héroes,
demasiado débiles para correr, demasiado caro dispararles,
cómo marchaban,
manos levantadas, rifles a sus espaldas,
hacia el fuego?
¿Cómo sus bastones mantuvieron vivas las llamas?
Demasiado duro de tragar para un fardo de alambre y una audiencia.
Demasiado implacable,
como el valle repleto del humo pútrido de nuestras muertes.
¿Es mejor en verso?
¿Puede una estrofa convertirse en sudario?
¿Dolerá menos si lo digo suavemente?
Si no me ves llorar, ¿escucharás mejor?
¿El dolor desaparecerá cuando el micrófono lo haga?
¿Por qué a cada palabra siento como si estuviera diciendo mi última?
Treinta segundos para el comentario,
y ahora tres minutos para el poema.
Mi lengua se seca de la misma manera en que morimos,
convirtiéndose en ceniza, sin nunca haber sido carbón.
Siento mi pierna izquierda entumecerse,
y me doy cuenta de que flexioné las rodillas,
preparándolas para el impacto.
Nunca uso zapatos que no me permitan correr.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Quiero dejar una nota positiva,
porque esa es la paradoja que ha sido esta vida:
en los lugares donde aprendí a llorar más,
también aprendí a sonreír después.
Así que, aquí va.
"Tienes una Gran Imaginación
o
400 000 maneras de llorar".
Para Zeinab.
Soy una chica triste
pero mi cara tiene otros planes,
concentra la energía en esta sonrisa, para no desperdiciarla en el dolor.
Lo primero que me quitaron fue el sueño,